hello and welcome to this video and all
of you happy new year this is a New
Year's video and I'm kicking off here
than do here with a closer Serena's
black yeah I went c5 him yeah just try
something else for the new year okie
doke even yeah and we should be three
set up pin this is my normal way of
playing it in the closed getting to that
point Vinick set up with black and would
see 5 & a 5 okay what's quite often
those form some f5 but currently have
that quite nicely protected so I kick
off with 94 bit should be 627 that's the
kind of plan okay yeah seems he wants to
go G form I think I'll take if he goes
gee for then 27 no it should be okay
I don't love my position but should be
ok I can also go Queen d2 trying to
complete development of course or King
edge to some rather non-committal moves
hmm and turn out in this one ok I can
now play let's do that check trying to
and ask him some questions here at g3s a
bit it's a bit awkward and I'm
threatening to take on f4 looking at be
too it looks a bit difficult for white
that's a very good position for me don't
really see what you should do now looks
like I'm winning at least upon maybe
more
multiple threats 93 93 and taking on air
for yeah this is also not looking to
grade now with that fantastic night on
f5 okay I can take that pawn and then
drop back I guess I should just take
material here and that's something that
I quite often neglect doing just take
take material and win I've been watching
some i watch been to blitz myself yeah
by various players and one player i
watch regularly as a young gustafson OT
always stresses his strategy of just
taking stuff yeah it's kind of it's a
there s 23 m and if you if you just grab
material you know what you're winning
ideas and yeah I should do that more
often and just take material okay it's
interesting both politics and night
takes is good I'll take will the night
just keeping my pawn sticking with that
strategy pawn takes is of course also
great because I that's 93 yeah i was i
just wanted to do this keeping this pawn
and keeping my fantastic night on f5
that's an extraordinarily strong piece
yeah and it's very easy to play ok
ticking they're probably not a good idea
mmm let's see how to do that yep let's
put this on the eval
doubling on the available playbook you
one now himself I guess
a 93 is my idea to break this position
of the rook only form so that we can
trade rooks and okay maybe here okay i
can check here first that's an idea or
here maybe check it's not a big deal
with the queen is a little bit more
active there and okay do a cheek or yeah
I think I'll take ok so Queen f2 maybe
493 or i can actually take h3 here as
Chad young would put it to take stuff
and check and another pawn
and check if you can remove in an end
game you know it's not going to be so
difficult I should have played 85 I
would have been a little easier even but
ok ok let's see how do we win this out
here and king over them and it takes a
while slowly until you get something
promoted white resigns ok let you have
the have a winning for that new here's
video our game so that close the soil in
here yeah I think this is just a normal
position we had this energy fourth is
what kind of fits with h3 my intention
was to take him and this is this for
example and I think it's equal issue
that is his move them f5 year five is
also possible he made that he played
that move that's a bit more with sharper
yeah I also liked a bit more by by the
engine certainly possible 95 year that
is already check already basically
losing him I have this this and the
thread on be true and there is no reply
now so 95 is basically losing the game
yes to go g4 or Queen d2 this is also
possible in both cases I can play a five
it's it's a it's an idea
and after this I have this this move for
the threat of capturing here institute
is evan is not a problem yeah all in all
a game that was decided here in the
opening and here i already have a very
good position if he takes this oops i
have 93 winning the exchange and here
yeah maybe in pawn takes is stronger
actually it's it's it's possible I'm
threatening but with those so group b 7
is not in but here I'm just keeping the
pawn and it's very important to note
that his bishop is very bad yes
absolutely no counter play in this
position by night is always stronger
than this bishop okay well thanks for
watching and again all of you happy good
and healthy new year 2016 thanks for
watching